The the the the the the the the
the the Put the fucking book down. Okay. No. Oh good. So now it's down. Now he's just closing his eyes and he's thinking. Now he's just memorizing. Can February, March? No, but April, May. Oh God. And you just came up with that. I just came up with that.
Unbelievable. I just came up with that. All right. Welcome to Smartless. I'm often down here in your whisper booth. My whisper booth listening to music when I get down here a few minutes early and I'll listen to music as I'm kind of setting up. Sitting sideways in your chair today, looking all sexy, oh, because your leg still hurts?
It still hurts. Yeah, man, it's a real. Sean, don't you have, from your list of 25 doctors you see on a regular basis, can you give those ones? I'm seeing Sean's guy. Yeah, so Jason, how did Maple's basketball game go? She has found a real stride. She had a tough first game and then the second game,
she hit the kid's version of fuck it and just started taking what was hers and driving the lane and raining threes. Raining down threes, I was gonna say, was she raining threes? She was. And all the kids, had a fat fantastic game She's got all this confidence and then went out the next game did it again next game did it again now
She's like one of the stars super star you make it in time yesterday because I know that we were on a call Were you a little bit late? No, no, I was I was fine And and and and and listener if you haven't heard or been bored by it yet. She is She plays on the boys team and she's the first girl in the history of the school, that's 30 years, to ever play on the boys basketball team. That's awesome. It's really cool.
Is there a girls basketball team or no? There is, yeah. Wow. That's awesome. She's a pretty remarkable kid that may. I love her. Yeah, she really is. And she's got an old soul.
Yeah, I connect. She's super smart. She's super funny. Here comes a butt. Hit, she really is. And she's got an old soul. She's super smart. I connect, I connect. She's super funny. Here comes a butt. I mean she's more mature than Sean. Yeah, there you go. I will say, by the way, also I want to say, Jay, I know you're an apology because I said at the end of our call,
right when we got off, I said, I said, hey, I like you in the crew, but I prefer you in a V neck. And that's not true. You look great in a crew neck. I literally, when I was putting on this crew neck this morning, literally, I was looking through my sweaters,
and I swear to God, on my kid's life, I was looking at the V-necks, because I remember what you said. Knowing it was a joke, but I was like, yeah, but you know what, he might be right. I can't wear a V-neck only because since I was a kid, my brother used to call me ET, because my neck is so thin and long.
He's an asshole. Yeah, I find that. I always wear crew necks. You know what, I can't wear turtlenecks because of my fat chin. The turtleneck, squeeze it up, and I will cascade my neck skin over the top of it. I can't pull off a turtleneck either.
What about a mock? Could you ever find yourself in a mock? Let me tell you something, Richard Erlich can wear a turtleneck. Dick Erlich can get himself into a mock. Richard Ehrlich, let me tell you something. Richard Ehrlich can wear a turtleneck. Dick Ehrlich can get himself into a... Old tricky dick. He's just unfair for other men. But I don't want to gloss over the mock turtleneck
made popular by goaltenders in the NHL in the 80s. Would you ever find yourself, Sean, I bet you wear a mock turtleneck. I bet you there's a photo. All the time. I used to work at Limited for Men, Limited Express for Men, and I'm colorblind, so women would come in and say, could you put an outfit together for my husband?
I'm like, sure. And I'd put like mustard yellow with greens, like I wouldn't know what I was putting together, but I would always put a mock turtleneck with it. I feel like I've heard this about you before, that you're colorblind, but I've forgotten it, but now that I'm reminded, it does explain a great deal. Really bad.
Think about it, just on the surface, it's not a viable thing, it's mocking the turtle neck. Do you know what I mean? It's making fun of, we get it. It's a half a turtle. But now in hockey, speaking of hockey, with the new neck guard there to prevent cuts, that it does look like the mock is back.
Yeah, it does. And by the way, I'm not opposed to those neck things, but I think if you look at the numbers of actual people get cut, I don't have the numbers ahead in front of me. It's rare, but it's worth the fix. Somebody wake up the guest, because we're coming to them.
I know, fuck. Here we go. Guys, today's gonna be tough for you, because our guest this morning is a truth teller. I know it's difficult for you two to deal with. The truth, given that you both act for a living and show business, couple of professional liars, couple of coastal elites,
but a hard-hitting investigative journalist like myself looks for treasures like this man. He was born in Birmingham, England. His father, a school headmaster, and his mother, a music teacher. He's got two Peabody Awards. He was named to Times Magazine's 100 Most Influential. He created his own church.
He started the first hospital to treat chlamydia and koala bears. And he has his own sewage plant in Connecticut. He also has 19 Emmy Awards. Guys, it's John Oliver. Wait a second. Oh, you have it down! Gentlemen.
Wait a second. There's the reveal. I've moved my paper over the camera. Like there's someone jumping out of a birthday cake. That's very good. Here's the crazy part. You said he's from Birmingham, which is maybe potentially true. I don't know if that's true.
It is. It is true, Will. I immediately was going to say, oh, he's a fucking... No, he's a fucking... We got a Villa fan on our hands. No, I thought he was from Liverpool oh, he's a fucking, no, he's a fucking, we got a Villa fan on our hands. No, I thought it was Liverpool. And I never would've guessed it, because I know that you're a Liverpool fan,
because you did start to spew out the starting 11 of Liverpool, and you know that I'm a fellow massive Liverpool supporter, and it was the best speech of all the speeches, because he's like Big Verge, fucking Trent Alexander, Arnold, I forget who else you... How far did you get? Let's hold on to our listeners just for a few more minutes before we lose them to a soccer talk.
Okay. Okay? Or football. Football. Soccer is an English term, by the way. I don't want to get into the origin of the word. Yeah, originally it's in English. He knows that. Anyway, John Oliver! John Oliver! What a pleasure to be here. What a lot of turtleneck talk I had to endure there. Anyway, John Oliver! John Oliver! John Oliver!
What a pleasure to be here. What a lot of turtleneck talk I had to endure there. It's our Regis and Kathie Lee morning patter, you know? John, why don't you have a podcast yet? I mean, you know, you got time. You're only working once a week, right? I think it's enough. I think a TV show
is enough. For me and definitely for everybody else. I think a TV show is enough. For me and definitely for everybody else. I'm primarily thinking of other people. Speaking of, congrats on the Emmy. You just won the Emmy. And well deserved. Very exciting. Thanks very much. Again. Really cool.
Again. I love the bass in your voice there, Jason. Again. No, again. I mean, but I'm saying, but it is an incredible accomplishment. And you know what? I mean, it is all writing, right? I mean, you don't stop talking for 30 minutes. It's insane and incredible. And I don't think I've ever seen you make a mistake. This man has got to be the best teleprompter reader in the world
or the best memory in the world. Other people can do it better. No one can do it faster. That's the promise. I will speed read a prompter. All right, now where do we find you today, John? Where's home? Home is the office today, so I'm in the office.
That's New York or Los Angeles? New York. New York. John, you know, I watch your show all the time last week tonight, and I'm a big fan, and when you first came, when I first heard of you and the show, I was like, who, like, hopefully you don't take offense to this,
but I was like, wait, who is this guy? And the second you started talking and the show, I was like, oh my God, I'm in, I love him, and it's funny and it's clever. And where did you come from? Ricky Gervais. Does Ricky Gervais deserve the, did he not recommend you to Jon Stewart? Does Ricky Gervais deserve the...
Did he not recommend you to Jon Stewart? Yeah, he did. Yeah, he did. The Daily Show was looking for a new correspondent. I didn't know Ricky. I'd never met him and he said, oh, you should look at this guy in England. He was floundering on the standup circuit. And that helped a lot.
Yeah. I didn't know that. That's cool. I did not know that at all. And you still love doing standup, yes? Yeah. Oh yeah, I love it. It's cool. I did not know that at all. And you still love doing stand-up, yes? Yeah. Oh yeah, I love it. It's the only way to relax. Really? It's relaxing for you?
I know that sounds insane. That sounds like a medical problem. But the only way I can truly calm down is doing stand-up. I mean, that says so much about your confidence and your self-image. And God, I want some of that. So you're totally comfortable getting up in front of a bunch. Now you've got stuff that's worked out, or do you kind of like to kind of riff it a bit
when you're up there? No, I mean, I like to have stuff that's very worked out and then I like to be distracted. Right, now how do you decide which part of it you will dedicate to stand-up and which part you will put on your show? How do you... Sometimes you're like... Oh, they're so different.
This show is so narrow in terms of the stories that we're attacking the way we're doing it. There isn't a way really for one to cross over into the other. So it's much easier to keep the two apart. Right. So the stand-up is more sort of stuff in life, in any area, your family life, yada yada, and then the show stays... Much, much looser than, like you say, taking a deep breath and then exhaling after 30 minutes.
Oh, that's so good. So how did a young man from Birmingham all of a sudden find himself a stand-up comic? What was that? Walk us through that a little bit. Well, I went to university and started writing comedy there, and then started writing my... started writing shows with another guy there. We really loved doing that.
You didn't happen to go to Cambridge, did you? I did. Yes, I did. I wrote with a guy called Richard Ayoade there. And so we were in a sketch group, and then we did shows, two-man shows together. Really loved it. And then after leaving... You could say you started as a compere. I like when people talk about starting as a compere.
But anyway, keep on. And he starts as a compere. No, but you're right, it would have been a better story. I started as a compere, just welcoming people to the evening. What's a compere? Like an emcee sort of. Like an emcee. Just a very fancy way to say emcee. Okay.
Who will be your compare tonight? I got it, got it. So you started writing with him. Yeah. Then left university and tried stand-up and really loved it. So that first experience was successful, yeah? First experience was successful. That's often the case. It seems that many people have a similar story.
They do a first gig, it goes well, they really like it, then you're chasing that high for the rest of your career. Normally the second gig is terrible. It definitely wasn't my case. I've heard other people say that, yeah. Yeah, so it's the same thing. You get too confident, you think, I can do this, people like it when I do this.
And then a second audience says, this is a second opinion. You can't do this and we don't. That is generally what happens. Now, if somebody gets lippy in the audience, is that something that throws you off or do you kind of lean into that? I love it. You do love it.
Of course you love it. You're a masochist. What's the worst one? What's the worst one? No, because if you're smart, then you can fucking cry. Yeah, go ahead. They're all good. The thing is, once you do it, it hurts at first, I will say.
Once you've bombed a hundred times, no audience retains the capacity to harm you anymore. There's nothing left for them to take. Right. Right. Dignity has been removed surgically by a hundred failures, you're left thinking I'm now... I could do anything. Was your stand-up always politically focused or no? No, I think for a couple of years it was just basically trying to make people laugh and not to leave the stage to the sound of your own footsteps.
That was basically it. So it's just an exercise in survival. Then once I kind of learned the fundamental tools of how to do stand-up, then I wanted to talk about the things that I cared about, which were kind of political issues. So then it became trying to learn a second time. It was throwing away the stuff that worked and running towards the things that didn't. But it's hard figuring, I mean, that process of going through this, finding the stuff that works, I mean, that's an arduous process
because obviously there's a lot of stuff that bomb you. You might write a joke, you might go like, hey, a lot of people say ballet is hard and I say just don't do it. Oh, Jesus. Like, somebody might write a joke like that. That doesn't sound like a joke, I know. But...
John, that was one of my first jokes I ever wrote. I was like 23 years old. It always works. Did you do that on stage? Or is this mirror work? I know, I really said it. Did you go in front of people expecting entertainment, possibly promised entertainment,
and lean in with that? Oh, here's another one. We haven't even heard the first one. There's not even a first joke. What do you mean, another one? Oh, that was your opening joke? I will say, I've come 180 degrees around to loving the fact that you went on and brought up ballet
to get an audience on site. Yeah, yeah, for sure. Now I like that a lot. Yeah, for sure. And another bad one, and this is gonna be real cringy. This is gonna make you come out of your skin. Because there's no joke here. And that's how bad I was.
I didn't know you actually had to write a joke. And so I would say, you know what's really weird? Boy, great opener. You ever wonder why? Let's have it. You know what's really weird is when you're at a dog park and you hear people call the name of their dog for the first time out loud.
So you know, you'll just be there and someone will go, mustard, come here mustard. That was the joke, I said there's no joke. It was so bad. The beauty there is you've identified something that I really think isn't weird. Hearing them say the name of their dog for the first time in a dog park, isn't weird. That's to be expected. Yeah
Should have been prepped for that one Sean. I Told you it was cringy. There's no joke. I This sounds like an absolute banger of a stand-up set. Yeah. Thank God we found you know what people say about ballet It's it's you're kind of like the signfold of like observational company, but the things you observe are totally normal expected Unusual you ever notice when people turn the corner they when they're in their car They turn the wheel of their the steering wheel direction. They want to go So alright so you're doing you're doing stand-up in in England and you're having a good time and you're finding some success and then Ricky Gervais either hears about you, sees you,
mentions you to John, John says, come on out and within a day or two, you're on television. Have I overly truncated the first half of your life? Within a single day. I flew to New York and then they put, I think looking back it was a standard tactic that they would get you on TV straight away so you didn't overthink it too much.
But I was jet-lacked. So I had just landed the previous night, then I'm on television. And then the crazy thing was in the audience that night was J.K. Rowling just watching, just sitting in the audience. Not a guest, just sitting there. So I did my bit, turned, looked straight at her, and it really felt like I must be having
some kind of medical episode. So I was so tired, so confused about what was going on. And there's J.K. Rowling saying, "'Oh, congratulations.'" That was very good. How bizarre. J.K. Rowling saying, oh, congratulations. That was very good. How bizarre. Wow. Now, were you comfortable in front of the camera?
Was that the first time you were in front of the camera? I think I was so tired, I was actually fine. Wow. And we will be right back. This show is sponsored by BetterHelp. You know, if I have a free hour in my day, sometimes I like to go for a run or I take a nap or, you know, the question is time for what?
If time was unlimited, how would you use it? How would you decide what is important enough to make time for? Therapy can help you find what matters to you so you can do more of it. Now I have chosen therapy with some of my available time and it's, you know, I'm sure some of you have as well. It's undeniable that it's even just talking to a friend, that that's therapeutic. So that's not really up for debate.
I think, you know, look, if you're thinking of starting therapy, give BetterHelp a try. It's entirely online, designed to be convenient, flexible, and suited to your schedule. Just fill out a brief questionnaire to get matched with a licensed therapist. And if you need to switch therapists at any time, it's no additional charge. Learn to make time for what makes you happy with BetterHelp. Visit betterhelp.com slash smartlis today to get 10% off your first month. That's betterhelp.com slash smartlis. Thank you to FanDuel for supporting this episode of SmartLis. Get
buckets with your first bet on FanDuel, America's number one sportsbook. Because right now new customers get $150 in bonus bets with any winning $5 bet. That's $150 if your bet wins. Within the app you have the ability to bet on all your favorite NBA players and teams with quick bets, live same game parlays, exclusive props, and more. And just the other day, a really fun bet, Will and I were betting each other when Sean would run out of money
from ordering too much Chinese food. Now, FanDuel doesn't give you the opportunity to bet on that, but I did win a great deal of money from Will on that one. Just visit FanDuel.com slash smart list and shoot your shot. FanDuel, official sports book partner of the NBA. 21 plus exclusions apply.
See show notes for full disclaimer. And now back to the show. So then the appearance on the Daily Show goes well enough to have another one and another one and even eventually hosting while John was directing his movie and you did that for eight weeks. It went so well, they said this guy deserves his own show perhaps, you start talking to them, but then HBO comes
around the back door and says how about with us and you can do whatever the hell you want. Cause we're not. I love that you've been able to put his whole answer and explanation into a question so he can just agree with a yes or a no. I'm trying to brag about my ability to do research on my guest.
Yes. John, thanks for joining us. This was great guys. Yes, that is correct. Do I have that right? Yeah, comedy central was very much not My own you know, I think I'm right. Yeah They what what John and I wanted them to do was let me have the summer so that he could leave each summer But they were not keeping that idea and my contract was up at the end of that year
So then HBO said would you like to do a show on Sunday nights? And I was talking to John about it. He said, you would be crazy not to do it. Yeah, it's so good. You're so good. Really? Now, are you one of those people that, do you seek out other comedies or stand-ups, or do you go to live shows?
Are you like, you know what, I do it for a living, I don't wanna go experience it? It used to be my favorite place to be. I've got kids now. So my wife, understandably, it got to the point favorite place to be. I've got kids now. So I got my wife, understandably, it got to the point of having a conversation. Do you need to go and do this? Or is this something that you want to do?
But I mean, like, do you seek it? Like, do you watch comedy specials? Are you a comedy? Okay, got it. Yes, absolutely. Yeah, I love it. It's one of my favorite things to watch and to do. So yeah.
You have a fave? Do you have a fave that's out there now? I just saw Jacqueline Novak's Get On Your Knees. That was fantastic. The new Netflix special. Maria Bamford is probably my favorite stand-up. God, she's crazy. Yeah, she's really funny. She is so brilliant.
If I could only watch one more stand-up in my life, I think it would probably be her. Oh, wow. That's so cool. Yeah, she's so unique. Have you ever seen the show that Mitch Hurwitz wrote for? Really good. No. stand up in my life, I think it'd probably be her. Oh wow. That's so cool. Yeah, she's so unique. Have you ever seen the show that Mitch Hurwitz wrote for? Really good.
No. Yeah, really, really good. What's it called, Jade, do you remember that? When he wrote that show for Maria? I don't. Really good. It wasn't called It's Maria. Is it like something like that?
No. All right, now before you got to do the HBO show. Lady Dynamite. That, that's it, Lady Dynamite. Lady Dynamite. Oh, you have a Wi-Fi connection, good for you. Oh, sorry, I should have mentioned, I gifted, I gave Sean for Christmas,
I gave him Google for Christmas, yeah. And by the way, I haven't said thank you, thank you. Of course, dude. Now you were, weren't you out like a roving reporter for The Daily Show? You'd interview people, did it ever get contentious? Were you brave with them? Anything weird ever happen with your interviews?
Oh yeah, it was constantly tense. Ever get punched in the face, shoved around, insulted? I don't think I ever got physically attacked. We definitely got threatened a bunch, but it never actually came to physical violence. And the problem is that the tension generally showed that things were going well. So I would luxuriate in that tension.
I could take a bath in those long, awful silences. Right, that meant that you were successful at what your objective was. Yes, exactly. Rob Riggle was a correspondent when I was there. Well, Rob can handle himself. Yep, which is the crazy thing is he couldn't stand those silences. So he can physically handle himself and he couldn't bring himself to inject that kind of tension. I can't physically handle myself and I loved it. But that's also because you had a six foot microphone
and a long lens on the camera, right? You were standing very far away from your subject. Not always. Sometimes it's just the length of an arm. If I've got a microphone at the end of my arm and they've got a fist at the end of theirs, there's definitely room to connect. Right.
But what you were doing and what they do on The Daily Show and what you've continued on your show is this great blend between satire, but also very important political issues that you bring to the public's attention. Is that something that was always, well, I guess you said, when you were doing your standup in England,
it was part of what you wanted to start to infuse into your comedy, yeah? Yeah, the thing with those interviews though, was that they're always tense for The Daily Show, because you always want to embody the counter-argument. So you are going to be really rough with the people that you agree with, and you are going to pacify and encourage
the argument that you don't. Yeah, whoever's saying the dumb stuff, keep them going. Exactly, then you just say, please tell me more. Say more about that. Yeah, of course. How did you hone, like I don't have that skill, news flash. How did you hone that? Like is that something that developed in college or after college? Or was there a person that influenced you as like,
you know what, I want to be more like that because I like how they approach this thing. For those interviews, you could only hone that by watching the edit. Going through the edit, watching your own failures. That was the way to sharpen that particular tool that you would watch yourself on screen think it would have been really helpful if I'd said something at this point that was funny. I literally hadn't edited a turn around to me at one point and say, hey, Paustin said, you know what would have been really helpful if I'd said something at this point that was funny. I literally hadn't had to turn around to me at one point and say, hey, Paust and said, it would have been great,
just any kind of funny remark from you at this point I could have used. Yeah, you're right. Really? I'll try to remember that. But that ability to be uncomfortable in those moments and ask uncomfortable things and obviously being provocative, right? You're provoking people to try to get,
to elicit a response that's gonna be hilarious because it's so misplaced, their views are misplaced or whatever. It takes a lot of, I mean, actually I was talking to another Cambridge grad who was at the dinner last night, our friend Sasha Cohen, and I was asking him about the second Borat movie and all that kind of stuff. I was saying like, fuck the balls to do that shit.
And he does it in the movies, and he does it really well, but you did it as a day to day because it was your job to go and do that kind of shit. I guess you tell me, you get better at it or you get less... You definitely get better at it. Does he, what's his answer? Does he disassociate as well? Because my head is always half in the edit. I'm barely there in the room. While you're present, while you're doing it, you mean?
Yeah, I'm just thinking the edit nonstop. So it means that I'm not really emotionally engaging with what's happening in front of me at all. Well, he's just, right, and he's got his, I guess it was a version of that, which is he's got his eye on the prize and he just wants to get the thing that he wants to get. He wants to get them to that point.
And so everything else is kind of noise until you get them to reveal themselves, right? Yeah, I felt that way about this. The craziest example of that was, I felt that way with the Dalai Lama. I flew to India to interview him, and I was starting to feel tense, right? Because you're driving up a mountain, there's monks there,
and I've taken two flights to fuck with this guy. I'm thinking, oh boy, oh boy, I think I'm on a slightly different page than everyone else on this mountain. And he talks for like ten minutes at the start, and I am literally kind of nothing. I'm not listening to any of this, I can't do anything with this. It's only when I start kind of needling him that he opens up and think, okay, now we're doing it.
Literally, you don't need to transcribe the first 10 minutes of that. Wow, wow. Right, because you're just trying to get that thing. Yeah, I'm not sure that fit that. I'm not sure he as an individual has ever been listened to less than I listened to him in the first 10 minutes of that. Nobody. But so, but through those efforts, and then, and also on your show, you're exposing and
enlightening people to certain issues, but even all the way up to and including affecting legislation, yes? I mean, there are... Well, I don't know. Well, but you'll be very humble about this, but please don't. And tell us, tell us what it, tell us something that you might be really proud of that you got done through very clever satire
and basically making the medicine go down easy. Well, I don't know about, yeah, I don't know about the legislature, making the medicine go down easy, that is something that we can do, right? So even in that AlarmR interview, what I wanted to do was get him off balance so that we could communicate what was actually going on with him and with the succession problem that he and Tibetan Buddhism has.
The same is true with when I went to talk to Edward Snowden. Incredibly smart guy, right? Not a great communicator to people that don't have the technical understanding that he does. So it felt like what we could do was facilitate the important information that he had into a form that people could understand. Right. Were you ever worried that like interviewing Eric Snowden that you're subjecting yourself to potential hacking and destruction of your life? Oh yeah.
我去采访爱德华·斯诺登时也是这样。极其聪明的人，对吧？但对于没有他那种专业技术理解能力的人来说，他并不是个出色的沟通者。所以我觉得，我们可以做的是把他掌握的重要信息，转化成普通人能理解的形式。没错。你有没有担心过，采访埃里克·斯诺登会让自己面临被黑客攻击以及生活被毁的潜在风险？哦，会啊。
It was terrifying. That was legitimately terrifying. We were being followed the entire time by the Russian Secret Service. They were angry that we were there. We knew that the American government were going to be angry that we'd gone. We hadn't told HBO that we were going.
那太可怕了。那是真的极其恐怖。我们一路上都被俄罗斯特工跟踪。他们对我们的到来感到恼火。我们知道美国政府也会对我们的前往感到恼火。我们甚至没有告诉HBO我们要去。
It felt like, but I will say, it's the same kind of feeling as when you're bombing or drawn to a tense situation. I was so happy, so giggly, just thinking, oh, everyone seems really mad at us. Yeah, giggling until... Everyone is the Russian government, the US government, and my employer.
感觉就像，不过我要说，这跟你在搞砸事情或者被吸引到紧张局势中时的感觉是一样的。我当时太开心了，笑得合不拢嘴，心里想：哦，每个人似乎都对我们很不满。是的，一直笑到……每个人指的是俄罗斯政府、美国政府和我的雇主。
But by the way, like, it's all fun and games and you're just getting a good bit and a good comedy bit until you're in fucking Moscow and you get a case of window cancer. And you know what I mean? I will say. It's funny you say that, because it's completely false sense of security that you get there thinking,
但话说回来，这一切本来都挺好玩，就像看了一场精彩的喜剧段子，直到你他妈的到了莫斯科，然后得了一种“窗户癌症”。你知道我的意思吗？我想说。你这么说真搞笑，因为你会产生一种完全虚假的安全感，以为
oh we're doing bits, it's fine. No one minds the jester. And they're following us the whole time. There's a guy drilling in my room. Is that true? The ceiling, 2am. Yeah, I'd hear this like zzzz, 2am in the morning. I'm talking to the ceiling saying, I'm sure you're trying to intimidate me.
哦，我们只是在开玩笑，没事的。没人会介意小丑。而他们却一路尾随我们。有个家伙在我的房间里钻墙。真的吗？天花板上，凌晨两点。对，我会听到这种嗡嗡声，凌晨两点。我对着天花板说，我确信你们是在试图恐吓我。
It's job well done. Let's both get some sleep. Wow. I'm leaving to the ceiling saying I'm sure you're trying to intimidate me. It's job well done. Let's both get some sleep I'm leaving here tomorrow. Your your your wife I'm sure can provide some Some security for you and some and some proper guidance. She's a war veteran. Yes I mean like that's it. That's a pretty interesting combination there that you combination there. Yeah, she can provide perspective. That's not all it was, a hard perspective. Oh, it was so dangerous over there, was it? Was it?
这活干得真漂亮。咱们都睡吧。哇。我对着天花板说，我确信你们是在试图恐吓我。这活干得真漂亮。咱们都睡吧。我明天就要离开这里了。你的，你的，你的妻子我敢肯定能为你提供一些，一些安全保障，以及一些，一些正确的指导。她是个退伍军人。是的。我的意思是，就是这样。那是一个相当有趣的组合，你，你们的组合。是的，她能提供不同的视角。这可不仅仅是一种生硬的视角。哦，那边那么危险，是吗？是吗？
Was it dangerous? When you say she was a war veteran, what did you mean? She was a combat medic in Iraq. Wow. She was, right? Yeah, yeah, yeah. Wow, fucking awesome. I'd love to hear those stories.
很危险吗？当你说她是个退伍军人时，是什么意思？她是伊拉克的战地医疗兵。哇。她是，对吧？对，对，对。哇，太酷了。我很想听听那些故事。
She nearby her? In the US Army. Yeah, in the US Army, that's right. Yeah. She wasn't there. So at any point was she like, hey dummy, let's just do your little stand up sets down at the comedy cellar, whatever it's called, and stop messing around, leave that stuff to the adults like me.
她就在你附近吗？在美军服役。对，在美军，没错。对。她当时不在那儿。所以她有没有在哪个时刻说，嘿，笨蛋，去喜剧地窖或者随便什么地方讲你的单口相声得了，别瞎胡闹了，把这种事留给像我这样的大人去做吧。
Yeah, I think a little bit. I think she sees a different side of me come out, because I'm probably a natural coward, and then I'll become utterly fearless whenever it's I think she sees a different side of me come out because I'm probably a natural coward and then I'll become utterly Fearless whenever it's in this inside a comedy bit. I know you've got the US Army behind you if things get hot It's kind of like the it's kind of like in hockey like a like a skills guy who feels tough because he's got an enforcer On his line, right? mean? That's exactly it. Talk a big game, but that's only because Vladimir behind me is going to take over as soon as your gloves come off.
对，我觉得多少有一点。我觉得她看到了我身上的另一面，因为我可能生性是个懦夫，但每当有，我觉得她看到了我身上的另一面，因为我可能生性是个懦夫，但每当处于，这种喜剧段子里面时，我就会变得无比无畏。我知道只要情况变糟，背后有美军撑腰。这有点像，这有点像冰球里，那种技术型球员，因为自己线里有个硬汉保镖而觉得自己很硬气，对吧？我的意思是？完全就是这样。吹牛吹得很大，那只是因为一旦你脱下手套，弗拉基米尔就会立刻接管。
Yeah, but is there like a thirst, there's obviously a thirst for this danger side of the correspondence and not just Russia or the Dalai Lama or whatever, where does that come from? Where does the, you know what, I like to live just on the edge, I wanna almost get in trouble, but I get out of it. I don't know, I live an unexamined life, Sean. I don't know where that comes from.
是的，但是有没有一种渴望，显然对这种伴随着危险的记者工作有一种渴望，不仅仅是俄罗斯、达赖喇嘛什么的，这种渴望是从哪里来的？那种，你知道的，我喜欢游走在边缘，我几乎想惹上麻烦，但我又能全身而退。不知道，我过着未经审视的人生，肖恩。我不知道这从何而来。
I'm sure, I've never looked inward. That's the most honest thing anybody's ever said on this show, by the way. Unexamined life. Can I guess, you're a smart person that is able to see all the inequities and injustices around the world and you have a platform and you're able to say something about it but you can skin it in a way that is also kind of entertaining.
当然，我从不向内审视。顺便说一句，这是这个节目上有史以来最诚实的话。未经审视的人生。让我猜猜，你是个聪明人，能够看到世界上的种种不公与不义，你拥有一个平台，能够就此发声，但你又能用一种同时兼具娱乐性的方式把它包装出来。
Or you saw that we're idiots and you want to come get some of that sweet American cash. It's got to be one of the two. Two things can be true at the same time. Little Colin B. A couple of my, two of my favorite battles that my Wikipedia page has told me about that you've had. Will you explain to the audience, let's start with the Russell Crowe back and forth. How did that, what is that, how did it come about,
或者你看出我们都是傻子，想来分一杯美国甜美的现金。肯定这两者必居其一。两件事可以同时成立。小科林·B。我的维基百科页面告诉过我你经历过的我最喜欢的两场论战中的两场。你能向观众解释一下吗，我们先从与罗素·克劳的来回交锋开始。这到底是怎么回事，这是什么，是怎么产生的，
and how did it end? So that was just a stupid bit that we were doing. The true joy is where bits get out of hand and they get added to once they've left our building. So with that example, he was staging a divorce auction. So he was selling. A divorce auction. Yeah, he was selling up all the memorabilia and stuff.
又如何收场的？那只是我们在做的愚蠢段子。真正的乐趣在于段子失控，并在离开我们的大楼后不断被添枝加瓦。就拿那个例子来说，他当时在搞一场离婚拍卖。所以他在卖。离婚拍卖。是的，他在拍卖所有的纪念品之类的东西。
Exactly. Wait, wait, he was divorcing somebody and selling all of her stuff? No, that would be less charming. He was selling lots of his memorabilia. He was selling T-shirts from like, the gladiator boots and stuff. 30-odd foot of gr people. T-shirts from like the gladiator grunts. 30-odd foot of grunt concert t-shirts and stuff. Got it.
没错。等等，他跟某人离婚了，在卖她的东西？不，那可就没那么迷人了。他在卖他自己的很多纪念品。他在卖像角斗士靴子之类的T恤。三十多英尺的格斗，人们的。像角斗士粗鲁行径那样的T恤。三十多英尺的粗鲁音乐会T恤之类的。明白了。
Exactly. And so we bought his jockstrap from the movie Cinderella Man. Sure. And we sent it to the last remaining blockbuster in Alaska as a kind of way to try and keep it open. He found out about it. And I wasn't sure. It didn't feel
没错。所以我们买下了他在电影《铁拳男人》里穿过的运动护身符。当然。我们把它寄给了阿拉斯加最后一家存活的百视达录像带租赁店，以此作为试图让它保持营业的一种方式。他发现了这件事。我不确定。当时我觉得
to me at the time that Russell Crowe was well known for his enjoyment in Bon Ami. He seemed like a rough-edged soul. Then we get the message that he is using the money that we've spent on his leather Cinderella Man jockstrap to start a Koala Chlamydia ward in my name at the Sydney Zoo. I can't tell you how much joy that put in my soul. Of course. It's such a good joke. First of all, is chlamydia a thing with koala bears? Huge. It's a huge thing.
罗素·克劳并不以喜欢博纳米清洁剂而闻名。他看起来是个脾气暴躁的人。然后我们接到消息说，他正用我们花在他那条旧皮质《铁拳男人》运动护身符上的钱，在悉尼动物园以我的名义建立一个考拉衣原体病房。我无法形容这给我的灵魂带来了多少快乐。当然。这笑话太棒了。首先，考拉真的有衣原体吗？超多。那是个极大的问题。
But truly. Yes, it is a massive problem. Come on. Did you not know that? It's the perfect joke. They all have chlamydia. I didn't know that either. Why, how?
但真的。是的，这是一个巨大的问题。拜托。你难道不知道吗？这是个完美的笑话。它们都得了衣原体。我也不知道这一点。为什么，怎么会？
What are you talking about? Are they ill? Do you really not know that? Because they're fucking each other nonstop. What, they do? Yeah. They're like bunnies? They're diseased tiny bears.
你在说什么？它们生病了吗？你真的不知道吗？因为它们他妈的在不停地做爱。什么，真的吗？对。它们就像兔子一样？它们是带病的极小熊。
So then the bears have this STD. Yes. Yeah. And Russell Crowe sets up a specific ward at the animal hospital and puts your name on it. In your name. Yes. God bless. In your name, yes. God bless.
所以这些熊得了这种性病。是的。对。然后罗素·克劳在动物医院设立了一个专门的病房，还挂上了你的名字。以你的名义。是的。上帝保佑。以你的名义，是的。上帝保佑。
It's a perfect joke. I've got all the time in the world for shit like that, for him doing that. Yes, it's a perfect, he elevated our joke. He handled it perfectly. He also managed to highlight a very real, albeit very funny issue among the Koala community. It was staggered by how good that joke was.
这是个完美的笑话。对于这种破事，对于他做出这种举动，我有的是时间。是的，这是一个完美的笑话，他升华了我们的笑话。他处理得完美无缺。他还设法强调了考拉群体中一个非常现实、尽管极其搞笑的问题。这个笑话的精妙程度让我大吃一惊。
And was that the end of it? Or did you go down there? No, the beauty was, this is how good that joke was. And was that the end of it? Or did you go down there? No, the beauty was. This is how good it was. Go host a benefit. That's the only way. We shut down the show the next week. We were kind of, you can't, this show's finished.
那就结束了吗？还是说你亲自去了那里？不，美妙之处在于，这个笑话就是这么绝妙。那就结束了吗？还是说你亲自去了那里？不，美妙之处在于。就是这么绝妙。去主持一个慈善义演吧。那是唯一的办法。我们第二周就把节目停播了。我们当时觉得，你不能，这个节目完了。
Nothing better than this can ever happen. Then we were going to start the next show with a bit that he'd done. I kind of wrote to him, hey, here's the idea. He said, yeah, I'll do it. I'll be honest, I don't think, I'm not sure you're elevating the joke anymore. And the brutal thing was he was completely right.
比这更好的事情再也不会发生了。然后我们打算用他做的一个段子来开启下一期节目。我有点写信给他，嘿，这是个想法。他说，行，我来做。说实话，我觉得，我不再确定你是否还能让这个笑话更上一层楼了。而残酷的是，他完全是对的。
Huh? Russell Crowe, the comedy doctor. You're right, yeah, fuck, you're right. Eventually at the end of the year, he came back and he did something, first of all, the big movie parody, and we returned it to him. But at that moment, it was a really solid comedic note from Russell Crowe.
啊？罗素·克劳，喜剧医生。你说得对，是的，他妈的，你说得对。最后到了年底，他回来了，他做了一件事，首先，那个宏大的电影恶搞，然后我们把它还给了他。但在那一刻，那是罗素·克劳非常扎实的一个喜剧包袱。
God bless him, man. That's fucking funny. What a funny dude. All right, now take us to the Connecticut sewer plant. Again, another perfect example, right? We're trying to do a story about, I think it was jury selection. And very dry, very dry story.
上帝保佑他，伙计。太他妈搞笑了。真是个有趣的家伙。好了，现在带我们去康涅狄格州的污水处理厂。同样，又是一个完美的例子，对吧？我们当时试图做一个关于，我想是挑选陪审团的节目。非常枯燥，非常枯燥的故事。
And so one of our writers, Owen, wrote a drive-by joke just shitting on Danbury, Connecticut. Literally put no thought into it whatsoever. Just bang, Danbury, Connecticut's getting it. Because they were tilting the jury selection away from perhaps a diverse community they weren't paying attention to. Yeah, that was the large story.
所以我们的编剧之一欧文，写了一个顺便挖苦康涅狄格州丹伯里的随性笑话。字面意思就是完全没过脑子。砰的一下，丹伯里中枪了。因为他们把挑选陪审团的方向偏离了一个他们没有关注的多元化社区。对，那是大背景。
Just a sideways joke, throwing an elbow on Danbury, they didn't deserve it. The town of Danbury does not respond to this well at all. They're up in arms and the mayor then goes on camera and says, as a response, we have a brand new sewer plant here and we are going to call it the John Oliver Memorial Sewer Plant. And again, the fact it's the Memorial sewer plant. Add memorial there.
只是一个随口抛出的笑话，对丹伯里肘击了一下，他们其实罪不至此。丹伯里镇对此完全没有任何好脸色。他们群情激昂，市长随后出镜并表示，作为回应，我们这里有一个全新的污水处理厂，我们要把它命名为“约翰·奥利弗纪念污水处理厂”。而且话说回来，它是纪念污水处理厂这件事本身。加上了纪念二字。
John Oliver sewer plant, that's already your shit talking me with a shit processing plant. To call it Memorial. You're like, you've done it. You've done it. But by the way, they didn't do it on purpose. That's the worst part. They don't understand. I don't think they get the memorial part. I don't.
约翰·奥利弗污水处理厂，这已经是在用一个排泄物处理厂来冲我大放厥词了。居然还叫纪念版。你就觉得，你们可真行。你们太绝了。但话说回来，他们不是故意这么做的。这才是最糟糕的部分。他们根本不懂。我觉得他们根本没Get到“纪念”那个词的点。我不觉得。
I really don't. I really don't. I think that they didn't get it until after and you go, what a brilliant joke. And they go, yeah, thanks. Yeah. We'll be right back. We're brought to you in part by ZipRecruiter. Daylight savings is right around the corner and for most states that means we're going to have more daylight from March through November. By setting your clocks forward it may feel like there are more hours in the day, but if you're hiring it doesn't necessarily help you find qualified candidates for your roles any sooner.
我真的不觉得。我真的觉得他们直到事后才反应过来，然后你说，多精彩的笑话啊。他们则说，对啊，谢谢。好的。我们马上回来。本节目部分内容由ZipRecruiter赞助播出。夏令时马上就要到了，对大多数州来说，这意味着从3月到11月我们将拥有更多的日照时间。把时钟拨快可能会让你觉得一天多出了几个小时，但如果你正在招聘，这不一定能帮你更快地找到符合岗位要求的合格候选人。
There's only one way to do that, ZipRecruiter, and right now you can try it for free at ziprecruiter.com slash smartless. As soon as you post your job on ZipRecruiter, they send it to over 100 plus job sites to reach great candidates. Plus ZipRecruiter Smart Technology combs through thousands of resumes to identify who skills and experience match your job post. Spring forward with a new hiring partner, ZipRecruiter, and find top talent sooner. See why four out of five employers who post on ZipRecruiter get a quality candidate
只有一种方法能做到这一点，那就是ZipRecruiter，现在你可以免费在 ziprecruiter.com/smartless上试用它。只要你在ZipRecruiter上发布职位，它就会将其发送到100多个求职网站，以接触到优秀的候选人。此外，ZipRecruiter的智能技术会筛选成千上万份简历，以识别哪些技能和经验与你的职位发布相匹配。带着全新的招聘合作伙伴ZipRecruiter大步迈向春天，更快地找到顶级人才。来看看为什么五分之四在ZipRecruiter上发布招聘信息的雇主能在第一天内就获得优质候选人。
within the first day. Just go to this exclusive web address to try ZipRecruiter for free. ZipRecruiter.com slash smartless. Once again, that's ZipRecruiter.com slash smartless. ZipRecruiter, the smartest way to hire. Smartless is supported by Organic Valley. If you're like me, you love to start your morning off
只需访问这个专属网址即可免费试用ZipRecruiter。ZipRecruiter.com/smartless。再说一遍，网址是ZipRecruiter.com/smartless。ZipRecruiter，最聪明的招聘方式。SmartLess得到Organic Valley的大力支持。如果你和我一样，喜欢用最好的食材制作丰盛的早餐来开启美好的早晨。
with a hearty breakfast using the best ingredients. With Organic Valley, you can feel good choosing from their dairy products. Their products are ethically sourced from small family farms where cows spend lots of time grazing outside on organic pasture. Organic Valley Dairy doesn't come from those big factory farms.
有了Organic Valley，你可以放心选择他们的乳制品。他们的产品来自道德采购的小型家庭农场，那里的奶牛有大量时间在有机牧场上户外吃草。Organic Valley的乳制品不来自那些大型工厂化农场。
Their farmer families are real people who care about people, animals, and nature. I mean, listen, and I'm glad they go to all of this incredibly good work because I'm tasting it in the quality. I put a nice scoop of their cottage cheese in my scrambled eggs. Listen, don't make fun until you try it but they're bringing me a lot of pleasure with their eggs, their butter, a little dollop of their cottage cheese. I'm ready for my day. When you choose Organic Valley not only will you enjoy great tasting organic dairy,
他们的奶农家庭都是真正关心人、动物和自然的人。我是说，听着，我很高兴他们做了所有这些极其出色的工作，因为我在品质中品尝出来了。我在炒鸡蛋里加了一大勺他们的白干酪。听着，在尝试之前别嘲笑它，但他们的鸡蛋、黄油以及一小团白干酪确实给我带来了极大的快乐。我已经准备好迎接新的一天了。当你选择Organic Valley时，你不仅能享受到美味的有机乳制品，
you'll help to save over 1600 small organic family farms who are protecting over 400,000 acres of organic farmland and all the plants and animals that call it home. To find Organic Valley dairy near you, visit ov.coop. Smartless listener, visit ov.coop. Smartless listener, let me tell you about the Defender 110. For those who embrace the impossible, the Defender 110 is up for the adventure. This iconic vehicle's exterior and interior has been redefined with a thoroughly modern design.
你还将帮助拯救1600多家小型有机家庭农场，它们保护着超过40万英亩的有机农田以及以之为家的所有动植物。要寻找你附近的Organic Valley乳制品，请访问ov.coop。SmartLess的听众们，请访问ov.coop。SmartLess的听众，让我向你们介绍一下Defender 110。对于那些拥抱不可能的人来说，Defender 110随时准备迎接冒险。这款标志性车辆的外观和内饰已经过重新定义，采用了彻底现代化的设计。
The Defender's capability is legendary. Whether you're facing off-road challenges or harsh weather conditions, you can rely on their innovative camera technologies to deliver unobstructed views and effortless maneuvering. Plus, their powerful innovations like the intuitive driver display and award-winning infotainment system make sure you stay connected. I have seen this car and it looks so effing cool.
Defender的性能堪称传奇。无论你面对的是越野挑战还是恶劣天气条件，你都可以信赖他们创新的摄像技术，以提供清晰的视野和轻松的操控。此外，他们强大的创新功能，如直观的驾驶员显示屏和屡获殊荣的信息娱乐系统，确保你时刻保持连接。我见过这款车，它看起来太酷了。
I mean, it looks sleek and modern. It looks like a Mars rover. It looks like a Mars Rover. It looks like a spaceship. It looks like you could drive the gosh darn thing on the planet Mars. It's so cool and sleek. Ready for a wide range of adventures? The Defender family features the two-door Defender 90,
我是说，它看起来流畅而现代。它看起来像火星车。它看起来像火星探测器。它看起来像一艘飞船。它看起来你甚至可以在火星上驾驶这个该死的东西。它是如此炫酷流畅。准备好迎接各种冒险了吗？Defender系列包括双门版Defender 90、
the Defender 110, and the Defender 130, which seats up to eight. Learn more at LandRoverUSA.com forward slash Defender. SmartList gets support from Audible. Audible lets you enjoy all your audio entertainment in one app. You'll always find the best of what you love or something new to discover.
Defender 110以及可容纳多达八人的Defender 130。访问LandRoverUSA.com/Defender了解更多信息。SmartLess获得Audible的支持。Audible让你在一个应用程序中享受所有音频娱乐。你总能找到你最爱的最佳内容或发现全新内容。
They offer an incredible selection of audiobooks across every genre, from bestsellers and new releases to celebrity memoirs, mysteries and thrillers, motivation, wellness, business, and more. Audible is your destination for thrilling audio entertainment with highly anticipated new releases and next-listen recommendations for every type of thriller listener.
他们提供涵盖各个流派的令人惊叹的有声书选择，从畅销书和新书到名人回忆录、悬疑惊悚片、励志、健康、商业等等。Audible是您体验惊险音频娱乐的目的地，这里有备受期待的新书发布以及针对每一类惊悚片听众的下一本收听推荐。
As an Audible member, you can choose one title a month to keep from the entire catalog. Most recently, I was on the site, just the other day I got my daughter, my 12 year old daughter, who is, she likes to read but she's becoming more and more friendly with it and one of the strategies is listening to the book as she's reading along on the book.
作为Audible的会员，你可以每个月从整个目录中挑选一本据为己有。最近我上这个网站，就在前几天，我给我女儿，我12岁的女儿买了，她喜欢读书，但她对书越来越熟悉了，其中一个策略就是在听书的同时跟着读。
So we got her Better Than the Movies, which is this great young adult sort of like romance friend thing, whatever, written by Lynn Painter, and it's read by Jesse Walensky, and she's loving it. And she's ripping through the book because she's listening as she's reading, and it's just, you know, it's nice. It takes the burden off. Anyway, new members can try Audible free for 30 days. Visit audible.com slash smartless or text smartless to 500-500. That's audible.com
所以我们给她买了《超越电影》（Better Than the Movies），这是一本很棒的年轻人那种浪漫友情之类的书，作者是林·佩恩（Lynn Painter），由杰西·瓦伦斯基（Jesse Walensky）朗读，她非常喜欢。她正津津有味地读着这本书，因为她一边听一边读，而且你知道，这很好。这减轻了负担。总之，新会员可以免费试用Audible 30天。访问audible.com/smartless或发送短信smartless至500-500。网址是audible.com
slash smartless or text smartless to 500-500 to try Audible free for 30 days. Audible.com slash Smartless. And back to the show. Okay, so you start of your own church, Our Lady of Perpetual Exemption. Well yeah, is this true? That's true, so that was in our first season. Perpetual Exemption.
/smartless或发送短信smartless至500-500即可免费试用Audible 30天。Audible.com/smartless。言归正传。好吧，所以你创办了自己的教堂，永恒豁免圣母堂。好吧，是的，这是真的吗？这是真的，那是我们在第一季的时候。永恒豁免。
That's genius. We were was in our first season. That's genius. We were doing something about televangelists. And we got one televangelist on it. So we were writing back and forth to him for seven months. I think kind of sending him money. He would send us more things back saying, please put your hand on this piece of paper and pray and send me another three dollars.
这太天才了。我们是在第一季的时候。这太天才了。我们在做一个关于电视布道者的节目。我们联系上了一个电视布道者。所以我们跟他来来回回通信了七个月。我想有点像给他寄钱。他会给我们寄回更多东西，说，请把你的手放在这张纸上祈祷，然后给我再寄三美元。
Okay, three dollars. What are you going to send us now? Please put this little bit of plastic in your hand. Yeah, I remember this. And it'll curl up and that'll tell you which direction you should press. It went on and on and on until we eventually called him and said, hey, we've been talking to you for some months, we're going to do a show about it.
好吧，三美元。你现在打算给我们寄什么？请把这小块塑料放在你的手里。对，我记得这个。它会卷起来，那会告诉你应该按哪个方向。事情没完没了，直到我们最终给他打电话说，嘿，我们已经跟你聊了好几个月了，我们要做一个关于这事的节目。
You got any comments? And he, I've forgotten this. He said, no, no comments, that sounds fine. And then left our researcher, like at 2 and a half, it was about 2.30 a.m., left her a voicemail that was very much a comment. Very much a hard comment about what hell was and when we were going there. So then to show how tax-exempt churches are, we then started a church and got people to send us money and offerings. And unfortunately they did both of those things.
你有什么要评论的吗？而他，我忘了这个了。他说，没有，没什么好评论的，听起来挺好。然后给我们的一位研究员，大概在两点半，差不多凌晨两点半，留了一条语音留言，那绝对算得上是评论。绝对是一条措辞严厉的评论，关于地狱是什么以及我们什么时候会下地狱。所以为了展示免税教堂有多荒谬，我们随后创办了一个教堂，让人们给我们寄钱和供奉。而遗憾的是，他们这两件事都做了。
And keep going, so what happened? Well they sent tens of thousands of dollars. Tens of thousands, yeah. And then various offerings and we're pretty sure two cups of semen and that's when we shut the church down. It's the second cup of semen. But that's amazing to me the church down. It's the second cup of semen. But that's amazing to me that you can just do that and it be legit.
然后继续，后来怎么了？嗯，他们寄了几万美元。几万美元，对。还有各种供奉，我们基本确凿那是两杯精液，也就是在那时我们把教堂关了。这是第二杯精液。但我觉得这太神奇了，把教堂关了。这是第二杯精液。但我觉得这太神奇了，你居然能直接这么干，而且还完全合法的样子。
By the way, I knew I could see Sean's face and I could see the fucking wheels turning in there. I saw both hamsters get on the wheel and he was like, wait, if I do it, can I be tax exempt and then I can buy my own plane and I can buy a mansion and it's all the, did you not a little bit? No, no, the reason, because I'm fascinated by religion and I'm fascinated by- And you hate money? No, I am and just like, naming other religions, I mean there's
顺便说一句，我知道我能看到肖恩的脸，我能看到他脑子里飞速运转的齿轮。我看到两只仓鼠都上了跑轮，他当时想，等等，如果我这么干，我能免税然后买我自己的飞机，我能买一栋豪宅，而且所有的，你难道一点都没这么想吗？不，不，原因是因为我对宗教很着迷，我对——还有你讨厌钱？不，我很着迷，就像给其他宗教命名一样，我是说有
thousands of religions in the world. Every single thing in the world is invented right? Even religion is invented. How dare you. You just, what's that? How dare you. And even you just, so with that little stunt or whatever it's just proved that you can, I'm just, that's fascinating to me that you did that and it worked. Yeah, with some stories, it feels like it helps sometimes to show, if a problem is that there is a very low bar of entry for something, sometimes it feels the best way to prove that is to clear that bar.
世界上有成千上万种宗教。世上所有的东西都是发明出来的，对吧？甚至宗教也是发明出来的。你好大的胆子。你只是，什么？你好大的胆子。甚至你只是，所以通过那个小把戏或者无论什么，它只是证明了你可以，我只是，这对我来说太迷人了，你做了这件事而且成功了。是的，对于某些故事，感觉有时候通过展示，如果一个问题是某事的准入门槛非常低，那么有时证明这一点的最好方法就是跨越那个门槛。
So that's why we have sometimes done things in practice as well as telling people what's possible in theory. Right, right, right. And that's where things can get a little legally dicey and very, very fun. Yeah, yeah. I love it. You will oftentimes cover multiple issues in the 30 minutes. Sometimes you will dedicate
所以这就是为什么我们有时会在实践中做一些事情，以及告诉人们理论上什么是可能的。对，对，对。这就是事情可能变得有点法律风险以及非常非常有趣的地方。Yeah, yeah. 太棒了。你经常在30分钟内涵盖多个议题。有时你会把
the whole 30 minutes to one. How do you... Well, first of all, how did you come up? What was the genesis of the format for the show? Oh yeah. That changed a lot actually. Because we didn't have an idea of what really we were going to do other than there were a couple of stories that we'd done that some of the jobs away. That it felt like The Daily Show wouldn't normally have done. One was about aluminum pricing and one was about
整整30分钟献给一个议题。你是如何……好吧，首先，你是怎么想出来的？这个节目的形式是怎么诞生的？哦，是的。其实这改变了很多。因为我们之前并不知道自己到底要做什么，除了我们做过的一些被某些工作抛弃的故事。感觉《每日秀》通常不会做那种故事。一个是关于铝定价的，还有一个是关于
the city of Detroit I think. And it felt like oh we could do more things like that. So we did two test shows but we had a guest area built in because I thought that you just had to have guests late night shows so that one note that HBO had for us was you don't need to have guests if you don't want them you can just add to the time of the story that's great and yeah we couldn't have bit their hand off fast enough I didn't have to get up and say, this person is here now. Yeah, but I mean, huge credit to you and your staff.
底特律市的，我想。感觉哦我们可以做更多类似的事情。所以我们做了两期测试节目，但我们在其中植入了一个嘉宾环节，因为我以为深夜秀就必须有嘉宾，所以HBO给我们的一个意见是，如果你不想的话，其实不需要请嘉宾，你可以直接把时间加到故事的讲述中，这太棒了，是的，我们简直恨不得马上答应下来。我不用再起身说，这个人现在来了。是的，但是，对你和你的团队致以崇高的敬意。
You don't need anything else other than the results of your research, the shaping of that opinion, and your delivery of it. It feels like it's better to live or die that way. And I think we're very, very lucky because we don't have to take ad breaks. And I do think what we need is a trapped audience. Because it's not like you can hold people's attention,
除了你的研究成果、观点的塑造以及你的精彩呈现，你什么都不需要。感觉以这种方式生存或消亡会更好。而且我认为我们非常非常幸运，因为我们不需要插播广告。而且我认为我们需要的是一个被困住的观众。因为这不像是你能抓住人们的注意力，
say, OK, we're going to let Twix tell you how delicious it is for three and a half minutes. Then you need to remember, we're coming back into this story about facial recognition technology, exactly where we left off. Also, the fact that there is no ad support on HBO, you don't need to worry about offending any brand. So you'd set free reign.
然后说，好吧，我们要让特克斯（Twix）给你讲三分钟半它有多美味。然后你需要记住，我们要回到这个关于面部识别技术的报道中，从刚才离开的地方继续。另外，由于HBO没有广告赞助，你不需要担心冒犯任何品牌。所以你可以完全自由驰骋。
That's a huge deal. That's a massive, massive deal. You get to build your own momentum. One of the things I like, when you get on a subject, you get to drive the momentum, and you don't have to take those breaks where you lose it. You can keep doubling down and compounding the energy and the focus.
这是一件大事。这绝对是一件大事。你可以建立属于自己的势头。我喜欢的一点是，当你进入一个主题时，你可以推动这种势头，而不必去经历那些让你分心的休息时间。你可以不断加码，将注意力和能量成倍放大。
And as you get sharper and sharper by the end of the thing, and you actually get more animated and more into it. And that's part of the allure of what you're doing, is that, you know, making that point of shedding all the shit and getting to it. If you were to have ad breaks, it would take away that energy. Yeah, it'd be tough.
随着你在节目结束时变得越来越犀利，你实际上会变得更加充满活力，更加投入其中。这也是你所做事情的魅力所在，你知道的，抛开所有的废话直奔主题。如果你有广告插播，就会消解这种能量。是的，那会很难。
I think that's one of the reasons I talk so fast. It isn't just that we're racing the clock. Sometimes it is that energy of, you don't leave, don't leave yet, don't tough. I think that's one of the reasons I talk so fast It's just that we're racing the clock sometimes it is that energy of you don't leave don't leave don't leave I know this sounds bad. Yeah, yeah, we're talking about the lethal injections, but please don't leave Go go go go go and we've been lucky to HBO sometimes gives us more time if we realize this can't fit into the show anymore We're not actually a 30 minute show anymore. We're 35 minutes Oh, that's and sometimes we're 40 or 45 minutes if If we say to them, can we please have 10 more minutes because there's stuff I can't cut out of this.
我想这也是我语速那么快的原因之一。不仅仅是因为我们在与时间赛跑。有时也是那种能量，你别走，别走，别走，别觉得艰难。我想这也是我语速那么快的原因之一，不仅仅是因为我们在与时间赛跑，有时也是那种能量，你别走，别走，别走。我知道这听起来很糟。对，对，我们在谈论死刑注射，但请千万别走。走，走，走，走。我们也很幸运，如果我们意识到这些内容再也塞不进节目时，HBO有时会给我们更多时间。我们其实已经不再是一个30分钟的节目了。我们是35分钟的节目。哦，那是，有时我们是40分钟或45分钟，如果我们
Yeah, that's nice. Because you'll time your monologue, right? Yes, oh yeah, down to a second. Got it. Yeah, well I remember they did the same thing. Sometimes in entourage, they hadn't finished telling the story that they needed to tell and they would go over. You know, they'd have something really important.
对他们说，请再给我们10分钟好吗，因为有些东西我实在剪不掉。是的，这很好。因为你会计算你的独白时间，对吧？是的，哦，是的，精确到秒。明白了。是的，我记得他们也做过同样的事情。有时在《明星伙伴》里，他们还没讲完他们需要讲述的故事，他们就会超时。你知道的，他们会有一些非常重要的事情。
They were like, they were gonna go for lunch on Fairfax. And like, they didn't have time to get to that. And I'm so glad you brought that up. We are standing on the shoulders of Dark Ellen and Entourage. We couldn't have done what we'd done unless they, thank you for giving the comment. We're all standing on those shoulders, believe me. Now, what is your process of finding these stories?
他们当时打算去费尔法克斯吃午饭。结果，他们没有时间讲到那个。我很高兴你提到了这一点。我们是站在黑暗的埃伦和《明星伙伴》的肩膀上。如果没有他们，我们就不可能做到今天这样，谢谢你提出这个评论。我们都站在那些肩膀上，相信我。那么，你寻找这些故事的过程是怎样的？
Is it, does it take many shapes and sizes, as little as you just finding something interesting in a magazine, all the way up to including what? And not just me, it's just the whole staff can pitch stories, and then if something is interesting as we'll give it to a researcher, they'll take it away for a week to work out if the story stands up, if it's been reported accurately,
是，它会呈现出许多不同的形状和规模吗，小到你只是在杂志上发现有趣的东西，大到包括什么？而且不仅是我，整个团队都可以提出故事选题，如果某事很有趣，我们会把它交给研究员，他们会花一周时间来查证这个故事是否站得住脚，报道是否准确，
if things are changing that might mean that now is not the right time to talk about it. If it gets through that first stress test, we'll give it to a footage producer as well to see if there's any footage through which we can tell the story. Only at that point would we have writers to have them just write an outline of a story
是否有变故意味着现在可能不是谈论它的好时机。如果它通过了第一轮压力测试，我们也会把它交给素材制作人，看看有没有可以用来讲述这个故事的素材。只有到了那个阶段，我们才会让编剧来写故事大纲，
without any jokes, literally just how would you tell this story? Then we combine those outlines and only then do they start drafting and that's about a six week process. Wow. For each story, so we're doing six stories at once constantly.
没有任何笑话，字面意思就是你将如何讲述这个故事？然后我们将这些大纲结合起来，只有在这之后他们才会开始起草，这个过程大约需要六周。哇。对于每个故事，所以我们一直在同时做六个故事。
Oh, that's amazing. And then it's always susceptible to total derailment based on the topical stories of the day. Yeah, we try to contain that at the top of the show the most of the time. It rarely will be that actually we have to hit pause on everything and just crash the show in a week That does happen, but we try not to have that because you are alive. Yes No, I mean or take delay you're on the same day. Yeah. Yeah, but but will you so when you're working on You know sort of six, six weeks in advance,
哦，太惊人了。而且它总是很容易因为当天的热门新闻而彻底脱轨。是的，我们通常会在节目开头尽量控制这一点。很少会出现我们实际上不得不暂停一切，在短短一周内彻底推翻重写节目的情况。这种情况确实会发生，但我们尽量避免，因为你是活的。对。不，我的意思是，或者说延期，你是同一天播出的。对。对，但是你会不会，当你在处理
so is it like Monday we're working on the thing, or is it all kind of combined? It is. So Monday is that thing, then Tuesday is that, and it's all color-coded days? Yes, exactly. It's a complex web of things that we need to do to the point that just after we've taken the show,
你知道的，提前大约六周的工作，所以它是像周一我们在处理这件事，还是所有东西都结合在一起？确实如此。所以周一是那件事，然后周二是另一件，所有这些都是用颜色标记的日期吗？是的，完全正确。这是一张复杂的待办事项网络，以至于就在我们录制完节目之后，
literally just after, we come back over the road from the studio and read the drafts that have just been logged for the next week's show. And then, yeah, the first day back, we'll be going through the outlines that have come in. So we'll only then revisit the show that we're doing next week three days later. So it's a lot of plates to keep spinning,
字面意思就是刚录完，我们就从演播室穿过马路回来，阅读刚刚为下周节目登记好的初稿。然后，是的，回来的第一天，我们会过一遍收到的故事大纲。所以我们直到三天后才会重新审视我们下周要做的节目。所以有太多的盘子需要同时旋转，
but it's the only way that we can do it. Wow. Now, in your hobnobbing around the political elite, as I'm sure you have an opportunity to at times, have you gotten your pocket stuffed with a bunch of cards and numbers for deep sourcing if you need it? It's a serious question. I know, I just like your phrasing.
但这是我们唯一能做到的方式。哇。好了，在你们与政治精英们交际的过程中，我确信你们有时有机会这么做，你的口袋里有没有被塞满各种卡片和号码，以便在需要时进行深度爆料？这是一个严肃的问题。我知道，我只是喜欢你的措辞。
Do you have some deep throats out there? Like that are really highly connected that can give you say, hey, listen, this is a real big issue and we love the way you make a mess and go down easy. You might wanna talk about this and I'll give you some choice. No, I'm not a hobnobber. Especially in the circles you're referring to there.
你们外面有没有什么深喉？就是那种背景极其深厚、能对你说“嘿，听着，这真的是个大问题，我们喜欢你把事情搞砸又轻松过关的方式，你可能想谈谈这个，我给你提供一些精选爆料”的人？不，我可不是什么社交达人。特别是你所指的那些圈子里。
So I don't have any, I think we've annoyed enough people that we're generally not welcome for some reason everywhere. God, if I worked for the government, I'd have my number. You don't think your nub is welcome by some deep throats? Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha The excitement in the pause, where, hold on, I've got all the pieces for this sentence, everybody be quiet. I know, I know, I know. I love it, I love it.
所以我没有任何，我想我们已经惹恼了足够多的人，以至于出于某种原因，我们在任何地方基本上都不受欢迎。天哪，如果我在政府工作，我会有你的号码。你真的认为你的关键部位不受某些深喉的欢迎吗？哈哈哈哈哈……暂停时的兴奋感，等等，我已经把这句话的所有拼图都凑齐了，大家安静。我知道，我知道，我知道。我喜欢，我喜欢。
And by the way, it was messy at best, it was just, it was an opportunity. I took the shot. You tee it up, he'll hit it. I didn't have a great look at the net, but I had enough that I thought that fuck, I might, it might go in. I'm turning around before it even hits the bed.
而且话说回来，这充其量也就是一团糟，这只是一次机会。我出手了。你把球抛出来，他就会打。我对球门没有很好的视线，但我有足够的把握，我想，他妈的，我可能，它可能会进。在它甚至还没有击中网窝之前，我就已经转过身去了。
John, I know you've done a lot of acting too in your life. Do you miss that? Do you want to do more of that? Or you're like, no, I'm good. Sean has a script. Not really. I haven't done a lot of acting and I think when I have done it, I'm not sure I would call it acting. Or...
约翰，我知道你在生活中也演过很多戏。你怀念那个吗？你想演更多吗？还是说你觉得，不，挺好的。肖恩有个剧本。其实还好。我没演过很多戏，而且我觉得当我演的时候，我甚至不确定那能不能算作演戏。或者……
Yeah. I remember I did these NBC sitcom community, I remember what Jonathan Banks, legitimate actor, came up to me before a scene and said, I just wanted to talk about you know what our characters are doing before this and I had to say, oh Jonathan I'm just gonna say these words in the funniest possible way. These words here with the yellow marker over the top of them? It really was. You know when actors act opposite a tennis ball, I will be that ball for you. I've never, yeah, that's funny.
是的。我记得我演过NBC的情景喜剧《废柴联盟》，我记得乔纳森·班克斯，真正的演员，在拍摄一个场景前走到我面前说，我只是想聊聊你知道我们扮演的角色在之前在做什么是怎样的，而我不得不说，哦，乔纳森，我只是打算以最搞笑的方式说出这些台词。就是顶部有黄色马克笔标记的这些台词吗？确实如此。你知道当演员对着网球演戏时，我就是你的那个球。我从来没，对，这很有趣。
In scripts, I've never highlighted lines because I just figured when it says my character and there's a line under it, that's when I talk. Like, I don't need to highlight when I talk. I just look for my name. They do it for you. Yeah. There's no reason to be confused as to what lines are yours. Right. Yeah, and you don't need to make a big deal. I mean, I used to do, I've done thousands of scenes with Jason and at a certain point they were like, do you want Jason?
在剧本里，我从来不高亮台词，因为我只是觉得当上面写着我的角色并且下面有一条线时，那就是我说话的时候。所以，我不需要高亮我说话的部分。我只需要找我的名字。他们会为你做好的。对。没有理由去搞混到底哪些台词是你的。对。是的，你不需要大惊小怪的。我的意思是，我以前做过，我和杰森拍过成千上万场戏，到了一定阶段他们会问，你想让杰森来吗？
I go, no, just tape his headshot to a C-stand and I'd rather do it to that, you know what I mean? A lot of early days for me. We did this one piece with Warren G. Harding's wax statues and we got Laura Linney, Jason, to act opposite that Warren G. Harding and no offense, watching those takes he realized, oh, she's been carrying actors for her entire career.
我说，不，只要把他的大头照贴在C形灯架上，我宁愿对着那玩意儿演，你知道我的意思吗？我早期有很多这种经历。我们曾用沃伦·G·哈定（Warren G. Harding）的蜡像拍过一个小片段，我们找来了劳拉·琳妮（Laura Linney），杰森，跟那个沃伦·G·哈定的蜡像对戏，说句得罪的话，看着那些镜头她意识到，哦，她整个职业生涯都在带飞演员。
She needs nothing, yeah. She doesn't need anything. Literally a wax statue wobbling in front of her and she's in tears, oh, yeah, you're a one man band. She is incredible, you are absolutely right. Now, how are you shutting off from all of your hard, hard work and intelligence and, do you do anything stupid, John?
她根本不需要什么，对。她什么都不需要。字面意思就是一个蜡像在她面前晃悠，而她却感动得泪流满面，哦，是的，你是个单人乐队。她太不可思议了，你绝对说得对。那么，你是如何从所有这些艰苦的工作、高强度脑力和……中抽离出来的，约翰，你会做一些蠢事吗？
Not really, no, I've got kids, so I guess everything that kids do is fundamentally stupid, so I'm stepping to their level right now. Right, you're getting on your knees and making funny faces and making dumb noises. That's right, I'm pretending that I understand the rules of Pokemon and I'm also pretending that they understand them. So uh... Wait, how old are they, John?
其实不会，我有孩子，所以我想孩子们做的一切本质上都是蠢事，所以我现在正俯身迁就他们的水平。对，你跪在地上做鬼脸、发出傻里傻气的声音。没错，我假装自己懂宝可梦的规则，同时我也假装他们懂。所以……等等，他们多大了，约翰？
Eight and five. Eight and five. Wait, three and five did you say? Eight and five. Eight and five, so you're out of Paw Patrol, John? Eight and five. Wait, three and five, did you say? Eight and five. Eight and five, so you're out of PAW Patrol, you're not in the Mighty One. Yes, I'm out of PAW Patrol.
八岁和五岁。八岁和五岁。等等，你刚才说三岁和五岁？八岁和五岁。八岁和五岁，所以你已经不需要看《汪汪队立大功》了，约翰？八岁和五岁。等等，你刚才说三岁和五岁？八岁和五岁。八岁和五岁，所以你已经不需要看《汪汪队立大功》了，你不在“威力狗”那一伙里了。是的，我不需要看《汪汪队立大功》了。
Now, is a lot of your day spent, especially these days, wondering who's gonna come back first, Thiago or Simikas? I mean, where are we at with that? Oh yeah, I mean, it's not gonna be Thiago. Here we go, we're back on Liverpool. It feels like that guy is an absolute Rolls Royce of a footballer, but I'm just not sure his body can stand up to the Premier League.
现在，你的一天中有很多时间，特别是最近这段时间，都在琢磨蒂亚戈（Thiago）和齐米卡斯（Simikas）谁会先伤愈复出吗？我的意思是，我们现在进展到哪一步了？哦，是的，我的意思是，肯定不会是蒂亚戈。我们来啦，我们又聊回利物浦了。感觉那家伙绝对是足球运动员里的劳斯莱斯，但我只是不确定他的身体能否经受得起英超联赛的考验。
Rolls Royce of a footballer. I love it. Now where does soccer come from? Is that true? That's a British term? Yes. Sorry, you can explain it, John. You know. No, no, go for it. So like in the way that like a lot of people call rugby rugger, right? It was called rugby football, I think. Rugby football. Yeah.
足球界中的劳斯莱斯。我太喜欢了。话说足球这个词是从哪来的？真的吗？这是英国术语？是的。不好意思，你可以解释一下，约翰。你知道的。不，不，你来吧。就像很多人把橄榄球叫rugger一样，对吧？它以前好像叫橄榄球足球。橄榄球足球。是的。
And the same thing, right? Soccer came from the association football. The association football, yeah. Soccer was not what we know as soccer was called association football to distinguish it from rugby. And so instead of they shortened the association to sock and they call it soccer. The English football. So instead of, they shortened the association to soccer, and they call it soccer. The English football. Oh, that would be genuinely how I'll relax,
道理是一样的，对吧？Soccer来自association football。对，association football。我们所知道的Soccer以前被称为association football，是为了把它和橄榄球区分开来。所以他们把association缩写成了soc，然后叫它soccer。英国的足球。所以他们没有直接叫，而是把association缩写成了soccer，管它叫soccer。英国足球。哦，那才真的是我放松的方式，
is watching Liverpool. Yeah. How are they doing this year? They're doing really well. They're doing well, I mean, this is gonna be a little delayed, but they had a nice draw yesterday, put them in the final of the Carabao Cup against Chelsea, who are, who the fuck knows how they got there.
就是看利物浦的比赛。对。他们今年踢得怎么样？他们踢得非常好。他们踢得很好，我的意思是，这期节目播出时可能有点延迟了，但他们昨天刚打平了一场不错的比赛，这让他们杀入了卡拉宝杯的决赛，将对阵切尔西，天知道切尔西是怎么进决赛的。
But they're doing great, aren't they? Yeah, they're very good. Are you all sports John? Are you like just sock just sorry I like all sports John. We're gonna go together We're gonna go over there together and And we're gonna go look at this. I showed the guy the guys know this oh Yeah, that's me and you're again. Oh,, yeah. Jurgen, you're gonna get it from... That's pretty good, dude. You're gonna get it. I gotta be honest.
但他们表现得很棒，对吧？是的，他们非常厉害。约翰，你是个体育迷吗？你是那种全天候……不好意思。我喜欢所有的体育运动，约翰。我们要一起去。我们要一起去那边，然后我们要去看这个。我给这几位看过了，大家都知道哦。对，那是我和你，又来了。哦，对。尤尔根，你要倒霉了……这挺逗的，老兄。你会遇到的。说实话，
That's pretty good. It's high level. Yeah. I might make a donation to the Chlamydia Foundation and now in your name for that joke. Mr. Oliver, this has been fantastic. Yes. Such a pleasure. Thank you, guys.
这真的很搞笑。水平很高。对。为了这个笑话，我可能会以你的名义向衣原体基金会捐笔钱。奥利弗先生，这太棒了。是的。非常荣幸。谢谢你们，伙计们。
You're very, very nice to do this with us. I mean... Such a pleasure. Thank you, guys. You're very, very nice to do this with us. I know you're busy. You're welcome. And you're much smarter than us. You dumbed it down for us. We appreciate that. Thank you.
你们能跟我们做这个节目真是太好、太好了。我是说……非常荣幸。谢谢你们，伙计们。你们能跟我们做这个节目真是太好、太好了。我知道你们很忙。不客气。而且你们比我们聪明多了。你们为了迁就我们把节目内容都简化了。我们很感激。谢谢。
We love it. We love you, dude. Keep doing what you do. Honestly, it's funny and it's fun. I love it. I watch it all the time. It's educational. Yeah. Thank you. As you're talking, I'm going to put the paper back over.
我们太喜欢了。我们太爱你了，老兄。继续做你正在做的事。说实话，这既搞笑又好玩。我很喜欢。我经常看。很有教育意义。是的。谢谢。正当你们说话的时候，我要把纸盖回去了。
Back into hell. So you can keep talking and I'm going to leave. I do not like compliments. Farewell. Thank you, John Oliver. Thank you, great John Oliver. Bye, pal. Bye-bye. Go Reds. That's a great guest.
回到地狱里去吧。所以你们可以继续聊，而我要走了。我不太喜欢奉承。再见。谢谢你，约翰·奥利弗。谢谢伟大的约翰·奥利弗。再见，老兄。拜拜。红军必胜。真是个很棒的嘉宾。
This is a great guest. Really good. Had you known him, Jason? Really good. No, I've circled him a couple of times at things we've both been at, but never. Doesn't sound creepy. Had the opportunity to touch him.
真是个很棒的嘉宾。真的很棒。你以前认识他吗，杰森？真的很棒。没有，我们在一些共同出席的活动上远远地绕过他几次，但从来没有。听起来可一点都不猥琐。有机会接触他。
You've just, wait. You've just kind of roamed near him and like sniffed him? Tighter and tighter circles each time I see him and never gotten close enough to put my hand out and say, hi. Hi. I did a couple, I've done over the years, I've done a few V.O.s for some of his bits for his show.
你只是，等等。你只是在他附近徘徊，像闻气味一样？每次见到他，绕的圈子越来越小，但从来没有靠近到能伸出手说，嗨。嗨。这些年来，我为他的节目的某些片段做过几次配音。
Oh really? He's been kind enough to reach out, yeah, that were like sort of semi-serious things and I've always been very kind of honored that he asked me, honored with a U. I really do, very nice. I do appreciate him or anyone else that is able to, whatever side of the political spectrum you sit,
哦，真的吗？他人很好，主动联系了我，是的，那是一些半严肃的事情，对于他邀请我，我一直感到非常荣幸，是用U拼写的“honour”。我真的觉得，非常好。我很感激他或任何其他能够，无论你站在政治光谱的哪一边，
I like that people are able to get info to us, facts to us, in a way that is not overly preachy or, I mean it's just like, we need that because we don't know where all the honest stuff is nowadays, because all the, you know. Honestly, it's as long as, you're right Jay,
我喜欢人们能够把信息、事实传递给我们，这种方式不会过于说教，或者，我的意思是就像，我们需要这个，因为我们如今不知道哪里才有诚实的料，因为所有的，你知道的。说实话，只要，你是对的，杰，
no matter what side you're on, as long as you can, or where you fall, forget side, where you fall, as long as you don, or where you fall, forget side, where you fall, as long as you don't take yourself too seriously at the end of the day, then fucking great. And it's the moment that your position is unassailable and that there's no way that you can, then you've lost it.
不管你站在哪一边，或者你属于哪里，别管什么阵营，就看你属于哪里，只要你最终不要太把自己当回事，那他妈的就太棒了。而一旦你的立场变得无懈可击，认为自己绝不会错，那你其实就已经输了。
Except when you're talking about facts, as long as everyone just agrees what what what are provable facts Then you can have your own opinion and stuff. But anyway, he's Another one that's I feel maybe overstated but he's doing a service, you know But you know, you know what? It is also I think part of I think that what's effective is is because he is English and he's not from here. He can kind of funny No, it's true and he can come here and here and have an outsider's perspective in that sense. Like somebody who's watched,
除非你在谈论事实，只要大家都能同意什么是可证明的事实，那你可以有你自己的观点之类的。不管怎样，他是另一个让我觉得可能被夸大但确实在做贡献的人，你知道的。但你知道吗？这也是，我认为有效的一部分原因，是因为他是英国人，他不是这里的人。他可以带有一种，不，是真的，他可以来到这里，从一个局外人的角度来看待问题。就像一个一直在看,
it's the same thing with Canadians. We're like really, I always say that Canadians, we grew up, we're very similar culturally, et cetera, and geographically, of course, but it's almost like we grew up against the glass and to make a hockey metaphor, we're right there, and we get to see it all. So you get to understand and see
加拿大人也是这样。我们真的很，我总是说加拿大人，我们成长过程中，在文化等方面非常相似，当然地理上也是，但这几乎就像我们隔着玻璃长大，用冰球来打个比方，我们就站在那里，把一切都尽收眼底。所以你能够理解并看到
what works and what doesn't work and you can have a point of view that is informed but not necessarily have a dog in the fight personally. And I guess that it's just a byproduct of being so foreign. It's a a by-product of being so fucking important. It's a by-product. You can deliver some facts just by doing a drive-by. By-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y SmartLess. SmartLess. SmartLess. SmartLess is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Rob Armgerve, Bennett Barbicoe, and Michael Granteri. SmartLess. If you like SmartLess, you can listen early and ad free right now by joining Wondry Plus in the Wondry app or on Apple podcasts.
什么行得通，什么行不通，你可以拥有一个见解深刻但又不必亲自卷入其中的观点。我猜这只是作为一个老外的一个副产品。这只是一个他妈的重要的副产品。这只是个副产品。你甚至可以顺便抛出一些事实。SmartLess。SmartLess。SmartLess。SmartLess 由 Rob Armgerve、Bennett Barbicoe 和 Michael Granteri 100% 有机手工制作。SmartLess。如果你喜欢 SmartLess，现在就可以在 Wondery App 或 Apple Podcasts 上加入 Wondery Plus，提前收听无广告版。
Prime members can listen ad free on Amazon Music. Before you go, tell us about yourself by filling out a short survey at Wondry.com slash survey. Hey, listener, it's Sean Hayes. Do you know when Crystal Pepsi was discontinued or what was in Al Capone's vault? If not, then you haven't spent enough time on Wikipedia. But that's okay because you can learn all about it on the new podcast, Wiki-hole, from all of us here at Smartless Media. Discover the craziest rabbit holes on Wikipedia with host Darcy Carden and her favorite comedian friends as they bring the cyber frontier directly to your tympanic membrane. And if you listen to WikiHole, you'll learn that's the sciency
Prime 会员可以在 Amazon Music 上收听无广告版。在您离开之前，请在 Wondery.com/survey 填写简短问卷，让我们更好地了解您。嘿，听众朋友们，我是肖恩·海耶斯。你知道水晶百事可乐是什么时候停产的吗？或者阿尔·卡彭的保险箱里有什么？如果没有，那你一定是没有花足够的时间在维基百科上。不过没关系，因为你可以从我们 Smartless 媒体出品的全新播客 Wiki-hole 中了解这一切。与主持人达西·卡登（Darcy Carden）和她喜爱的喜剧演员朋友们一起，探索维基百科中最疯狂的奇闻异事，将赛博前沿直接带入你的鼓膜。如果你听了 WikiHole，你就会知道这是科学上
term for eardrum. WikiHole is the wild, wild west of Wikipedia. Starting out on one Wikipedia page, they go from link to link to link to link, careening through trivia, oddities and unexpected connections until everyone wonders, how the hell did we get here? Follow Wikihole on the Wondery app or wherever you get your podcasts. You can listen to Wikihole ad-free by joining Wondery Plus in the Wondery app or on Apple podcasts. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
对耳膜的称呼。WikiHole 是维基百科的荒野西部。他们从维基百科的一个页面出发，在链接之间穿梭跳转，在冷知识、奇闻和意想不到的联系中纵横驰骋，直到每个人都在纳闷：我们到底是怎么来到这里的？在 Wondery App 或您获取播客的任何地方订阅 Wikihole。您可以通过在 Wondery App 或 Apple Podcasts 上加入 Wondery Plus 来收听无广告版的 Wikihole。本期节目暂无评论。点击转写中的任意句子即可发表评论。